there were three things that are  happening now that didn't happen in my  lifetime before and that i needed to  study and that was um an enormous amount  of creation of debt and the monetization  of that in a financial piece  the second is  the internal conflict  populism of the right and the left  that and with wealth gaps and so on  that and i like to measure things that  you'd have to go back to 1900 to see  those degrees of conflict which i think  are a threat to our system and a  democracy and could produce a civil war  type of situation  and third the rise of a great power to  challenge an existing great power and  existing world order now those three  things in their degrees individually but  also collectively last time they  happened was 1930 to 45 period and so  when i what i needed to do was to  understand  those patterns and those things